c'est parti d'un constat parce que
chaque année voit force est de constater
qu'on est en pleine déculturation c'est
ce que j'appelle perdre ses repères et
je me suis dit qu'il fallait trouver un
moyen de se réapproprier tout ça et le
jeu permet il permet tout en séduisant b
de réapprendre de tester ses
connaissances et heureusement je vois
que ça fonctionne très bien et
l'objectif justement d'occuper cette
place puisqu'il n'avait pas justement
quand j'allais dans les magasins de
jouets que je demandais des choses fort
la martinique mais il n'y avait pas
alter donc mais aussi dj il ya un
créneau à prendre et pourquoi ne pas le
faire donc trois jeux certes mais trois
jeux différents donc un premier jeu qui
est un puzzle avec la carte de la
martinique deux cent soixante pièces à
partir de 6 ans donc la cab la marque ni
qui représente avec les communes
donc chaque commune a une symbolique
donc on joue mais aussi on apprend on
apprend à positionner les communes et on
apprend aussi quels sont les atouts de
chaque commune donc comme on dit aux
gens jouent intelligemment un autre jeu
qui est un jeu de cartes
neuf familles c'est pas cette famille
c'est neuf l'objectif est d'apprendre un
peu plus donc neuf familles c'est le
volume ii avait déjà voulu
hélas le volume du avec d'autres
familles confiserie épices fruits de mer
plats traditionnels bijoux donc vraiment
apprendre la martinique de manière
ludique et troisième jeux qui a va ravir
le grand public c'est un livret de jeux
mots croisés mots fléchés mots codés sur
la martinique
d'autres c'est le petit livret à avoir
soumis bras pendant les vacances pour
apprendre en s'amusant